[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello martin hello walter
are you well yes
carrying on yes we have work to do let's
jump right in
and interesting
we're carrying on with john
yes hopefully in this episode we can
wrap it up yeah
what we want to say and then we can move
on again to what's happening in the
world but i'm sure that everybody has
been
really blessed because i know i have
in studying the word of god
yes you can't go wrong when you study
the word of god let's open with the word
of prayer
our heavenly father we thank you again
for one of these episodes that we can
discuss important things and we ask
therefore that you bless our discussion
enlighten our minds with the holy spirit
thank you god in jesus name amen amen
well
we're going to deal with the gospel of
john let us just look at one or two
quotes again to set the stage for our
study on for your ears only
it was at this time that christ gave his
disciples the precious instruction found
in the 14th 15th 16th and 17th chapters
of john
he knew that they must have special
instruction for unless divine power were
combined with human effort
their future work would prove a failure
he was about to be separated from them
they would no longer have him as their
visible counselor
to take the responsibility in all
matters they must be instructed
for were they to leave the divine agency
out of their efforts
they would not accomplish the work he
had appointed them to do
in all their ministry upon which they
should enter to bless humanity they must
build upon a divine christ
that's a powerful statement
a divine christ a divine christ so
christ
jesus christ
god
yes
today a great work is to be done the
holy spirit is to work through human
agencies a partnership between god and
the workers must be maintained
man works because god works in him all
the efficiency and power is of god yet
god has so arranged
that all the responsibility rests with
the human instrument
these are the appointed conditions of
partnership men are required to move
amongst men doing a divine work
god designs that they shall have power
from and high but if they fail to seek
for this power if they neglect to
improve the facilities which god has
provided whereby whereby they may reach
the highest standard
they fail to uplift fallen humanity it's
important this is a very important task
that god has
given man to do to be a partaker in the
proclamation of the gospel
but if you do it in your own strength
then you are
in trouble
it's like when we studied the
loaves and the fishes yes
who did
the multiplication christ did it's like
when you
sometimes you mentioned that if the
disciples had to do it they would have
divided
the loaves and the fishes but when
christ did it he multiplied it yes we
work on the principle of
addition
but christ works on the principle of
multiplication
so let us go to these chapters martin
because this is the crux of the matter
we're not going to go into a verse by
verse detail
chapter 13 deals with the last supper
and as we mentioned last time
when the disciples came to the last
supper they were still arguing as to who
was the greatest
and jesus gave them
not only
an object lesson
but a great spiritual truth as well
in the communion service that he
initiated at this very important
juncture
but we are dealing especially here today
with what happened
to judas
and how
the story unfolds
so the disciples had come together and
as we said they were arguing about who
was the greatest
and jesus showed them
that
they had to be
servants one to another
but he also
told them that one of them was going to
be a betrayer
and he says in verse 21 of chapter 13
verily verily i say unto you that one of
you shall betray me
and so they looked at one another and
they wanted to know who was it going to
be
and then jesus answered him and said
here it is to whom i shall give a sop
when i have dipped it now sop is a
morsel
if you read in the margin
in this middle eastern
setting
it is customary to have dips and share
and
dip your bread in whatever there is like
umus or any one of those things
and so this is what he was referring to
he it is to whom i shall give a sop when
i have dipped it
and when he had dipped this up he gave
it to judas iscariot the son of simon
i don't think anyone realized exactly
what was going on because this was part
of the the way in which they ate so
nobody took particular notice
but then he said to him
and after the sup satan entered into him
then said jesus unto him that thou doest
do quickly
now no man at the table knew for what
intent he spake this unto him
but verse 30 in particular is very
interesting to me
he then having received the sop went
immediately out and it was night
martin if you leave the presence of
christ
darkness it's darkness it's night
so the children of light remained behind
and from verse 31 which by the way is a
new paragraph
in my bible again this is bolded the
number 31 so this means in the original
this is a new paragraph
now judas had left
what you do go and do it quickly you're
not going to change your mind
you have passed the point of your
probation
go
and it was
night
and therefore when he was gone out jesus
said now is the son of man glorified
and god is glorified in him
now came the time when he was dealing
with the final issues and he had his
final group of
loyal disciples around him
and then follow the most precious
lessons that are very important to us
god be glorified in him god shall also
glorify him in himself and shall
straight away glorify him
little children yet a little while i am
with you
you shall seek me and as i said unto the
jews whether i go you cannot come
so now i say to you a new commandment i
give unto you
that you love one another as i have
loved you
that you also love one another by this
shall all men know that you are my
disciples
if you have love
for one another
martin
if we look at the christian church today
and we look at the strife
that reigns in many many places
and people can honestly sometimes ask do
they have love for one another
now this is after judas had
left so if we apply this to the time in
which we are living
and we must have love for one another
then we must be
one in mind
we must be
one in thinking
one in attitude yes and one in goal and
one in goal
and we must
love one another
and then men shall know that we are his
so in particular
this love will be manifested even
greater
once the judas principle has left the
church yeah so yes once the shaking has
done its work
then
these people that are left will be
one-minded
how do you achieve this
oneness you must have you must have the
same mindset you must have the same
doctrine they must be
unified in terms of these issues that's
why when jesus said previously in the
chapters that him and the father are one
that's the same they've got this one
mindset and that is the same mindset
that these people or us these at the end
will have to have to go through now it's
interesting that the disciples that were
left
were the ones that were going to
bring the message the message of the
early reign
under the outpouring of the holy spirit
and yet even at that stage
they were still going to deny him as
peter did
because all the disciples ran away
so in this in a sense none of them could
point finger but peter just went a step
further and
verbally denied him verbally denied him
and then come the instructions for their
ears only the most wonderful
instructions
and these are the things
that need to bind us together
these are the things that should be in
our minds and in our hearts as we
prepare to receive the latter rain
and of course chapter 14 begins with
that
marvelous
marvelous introduction
and it basically is the gospel in
essence
it's the whole bible in
just a few verses
let not your hearts be troubled you
believe in god believe also in me
in my father's house on many mansions if
it were not so i would have told you
i go to prepare a place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come again and receive you unto
myself that where i am there ye may be
also
and whether i go ye know and the way
ye know
that is the entire plan of salvation in
a nutshell
and if people were to study this
there would be far less confusion in the
world
and it says quite clearly
that he is going to go away
[Music]
that he is going to prepare a place
and that once this has done been done he
shall return
to take his disciples so that they may
be with him for all eternity
so you know
false doctrines in terms of
what happens in the afterlife
would not exist if you believed in in
these statements they're very plain
exactly you're not going to heaven
any time until jesus comes to fetch us
jesus will come to fetch it
and i go to prepare a place and i will
come again and receive you
so the receiving doesn't take place at
death it takes place when jesus comes to
resurrect the dead and all the previous
chapters that we discussed made this
very clear i am the resurrection and the
life
lazarus come forth was a demonstration
of what will happen
at the end of time
and this part where jesus tells them
whether i go you know
and the way you know yes because he is
the way the truth and the life they know
him if you know him you know the way
it's interesting that at this stage
thomas
still inquires
how do we know the way
and jesus said to him then quite plainly
this is absolute straight talk there's
no parable nothing here
don't you understand he says to him i am
the way the truth and the life
no man cometh unto the father but by me
by this simple statement falls every
false religion on the
in this world
go on
god you cannot
go to heaven if you don't know the way
and if you want to understand god you
have to read verse seven
if you had known me you should have
known my father also and from henceforth
ye know him and have seen him
in what sense have they seen him
in the character of christ
just as christ is so is the father so
this
dichotomy that we have in the world
and
the jesus seminar and all of these
groupings that say we should love the
father and we should love the son and
and hate the father
it's ridiculous once you
read the bible and you understand the
mindset of the plan of salvation it also
comes back to the god of the old
testament and the god of the new
testament there's
no such thing no it's the same it's
exactly the same
and the fact that the judgments were
shown in type
doesn't negate the fact that there will
be a judgment in anti-type that will be
exactly the same exactly as that in the
old testament
and yet philip again says show us the
father and it will suffice us
and jesus said have i been so long with
you and yet has thou not known me philip
he that has seen me has seen the father
and how sayest thou then show us the
father
so this dichotomy of thinking that we
have in the world
would disappear if people studied john
chapter 14.
and it is alive and well and living
today in the world
unbelievable
catholicism goes even further
and says nobody comes to the father
except by the sun but nobody comes to
the son except by mary that's ridiculous
where do you read that
nowhere
believers thou not that i am in the
father and the father in me the words
that i speak unto you i speak not of
myself but the father that
dwelleth in me he doeth the works
believe me that i am in the father and
the father in me or else believe me for
the very work's sake
and then he has this amazing promise
verily verily i say unto you
he that believeth in me the works that i
do shall he do also and greater works
than these shall he do because i go unto
the father
now martin nobody can do greater works
than god
nobody can do greater work than opening
the eyes of someone that has been born
blind
so in what sense must we understand this
verse it will have a wider application
correct
in extent the work will be greater
because christ preached locally
but the disciples will preach
universally
and
imagine
the power that must attend the message
in that first century
after christ
the whole world had been reached yes
even china and you can go back into
the history of china and you can read in
the writing and the symbols that they
use the entire gospel is ensconced in
those symbols
and then that was overturned again and
they returned to their old ways
and uh i'm sure god wants to awaken
that memory in the last days in which we
live
so nations like japan
and china and all of these
where the gospel of christ has been
basically obliterated again and largely
due to the actions of the jesuits
these people will one day have to give
an account for what they have done to
the gospel of christ
from verse 13 we have the promise that
you can ask anything in his name
that will i do that the father may be
glorified in the son this is again one
that has been
misconstrued and misapplied
anything in his name means anything in
harmony with his character
selfless character
anything you ask
in terms of your
drive to spread the gospel to others
will be answered by if your mindset is
that of
christ and the father then
that what you ask will be in line what
what their mindset is correct
now verse 15 again is a new paragraph
and it says if you love me keep my
commandments
now
if this is
jesus's direct
instruction
to the disciples
going out to preach to the world
how important is that commandment so
that was something that was absolutely
essential for them to receive the former
reign
how essential is it for us then to
receive the latter rain
precisely the same
so it says there if
that means
conditional right you have you have a
choice
if you love me
keep my commandments
and then there's a consequence right a
result
and i will pray the father and he shall
give you another comforter that he may
abide with you forever so martin what is
the condition
for receiving the comforter
keeping the commandments there's no
doubt about it no doubt
so how can you turn it around and say
that the commandments have been done
away with and all you need is the holy
spirit yes
it's impossible it's impossible
absolutely impossible so this negates an
entire religious system
that is prevalent in the world today
and then he tells us and qualifies who
the comforter is even the spirit of
truth whom the world cannot receive
because it sees him not neither knoweth
him but ye know him for he dwelleth with
you and shall be in you
so what is the condition again for the
holy spirit to dwell in you and be in
you keeping the commandments you must
know christ yep you must know the way
the truth and the life and you must keep
the commandments love him that's it
that's it
it's not rocket science
so can you separate the law from the
gospel
no not at all
i will not leave you comfortless
i will come to you yet a little while
and the world sees me no more but ye see
me because i live ye shall live
also. so our life is bound up in the
life of christ
and as he was obedient
so we have to be obedient
all that day you shall know that i am in
my father and you in me
and i in you
and then he reiterates it he that hath
my commandments and keepeth them
he it is that love with me and he that
loveth me shall be loved of my father
and i will love him and will manifest
myself to him
what is the condition
of
for christ to manifest himself to his to
his disciples and his people it's
in you keeping the commandments but
it buckles the mind that the churches
have
moved in the direction of
anomia
getting rid of the law of god
unbelievable
i don't think
if you read verses 15 to 21 these words
of jesus
this
admonition that christ gives them and he
begins and ends it
what do you need keep the commandments
it's interesting
that judas not iscariot
said
how is it that you will manifest
yourself to us
it's almost like
god is instilling
this this want of information in his
disciples so that he can answer answer
exactly yeah
like previously thomas was confused he's
asking the old time now judah's not
iscariot is asking the same doesn't the
show what kind of a teacher jesus is
right
now when we when we look at this answer
he says to him
if a man loves me
he will keep my words so nice changes it
slightly from commandments to words so
he will keep my words and my father will
love him and we will come unto him and
make our abode with him
it's interesting that
we is plural right
we will come
so
you are bound to keep the commandments
and you are bound to believe the word
when the son of man comes will he find
faith on this earth
that's a question
and if you look at the various
denominations in the world how many of
them have for example embraced evolution
i think most
most of them there are some that haven't
southern baptists say they still believe
in creation
the seventh-day adventists of course
believe in creation
the catholic church has denied the
creation account they believe and have
propagated and introduced the big bang
theory through their jesuit
influences
so it is a rather sad state of affairs
that those that seem to wield the power
within christianity deny the very tenets
of the bible
he that loveth me not
keepeth not my sayings and the word
which you hear is not mine but the
fathers which you sent me
these things have i spoken unto you
being yet present with you but
the comforter which is the holy ghost
whom the father will send in my name he
shall teach you all things
and bring all things to your remembrance
whatsoever i have said unto you
that's a tremendous promise
so he will teach you all things how does
he teach you
it brings remembrance
well you have to go back to see if you
keep my words so you'll have to
internalize the word you'll have to
write so it's not going to teach you
apart from the word right
you have to go back and if you read and
that you'll bring to remembrance what
you've read and if you haven't read it
you can't remember it then you can't
remember it's as simple as that
and then the rest of this chapter
14 he just reiterates that he has given
them peace
so we can have peace in the midst of the
storm that's why it was necessary to
browse through them
so that you can see the emphasis and the
necessity yes so will we face
storms he promised us we all all right
storms and in the midst of the storm can
we have peace yes because he has the
voice to calm the storm
when you think about it
there was this terrific storm and jesus
fell asleep in the boat
right
and the disciples said master do you not
care
that we are perishing don't you care
how can you sleep under these
circumstances well don't we feel the
same when everything is going wrong and
we've got all this
problems we are very inclined to say do
you not care
but uh the fact that he is asleep in the
boat should be enough right exactly
so martin now that we've spoken about
the holy spirit let's just read another
statement here
this one is about the nature of the holy
spirit that is a mystery
men cannot explain it
because the lord has not revealed it to
them you know even to nicodemus said
it's like the wind it lifteth here and
there you don't know where it comes to
from you don't know where it's going to
men having fanciful views may bring
together passages of scripture and put a
human construction on them
but the acceptance of these views will
not strengthen the church regarding such
mysteries which are too deep for human
understanding
silence is golden
so while we are on the subject of the
holy spirit
if we try to pin it down and define it
exactly what the holy spirit is
we are dealing with a subject that has
not been revealed to humanity
so silence is golden
deal with the manifestations
dwell upon what the role of the holy
spirit is that's true what we've just
read
read your bible
study it and the holy spirit will bring
to remembrance that that you need to to
help others correct so what is the
office of the holy spirit it is
distinctly specified in the words of
christ when he comes
he will reprove the world of sin
and righteousness and judgment
that's john chapter 16 we'll get to that
one it is the holy spirit that convicts
of sin
if the sinner responds to the quickening
influence of the spirit he will be
brought to repentance
and aroused to the importance of obeying
the divine requirements is the statement
in harmony with what we've read so far
100 100 so let's go to chapter 15.
the burden of chapter 15 is that christ
is the true vine
you cannot
be a branch and be alive if you are not
grafted into that vine
verse 2 says every branch in me that
beareth not fruit he taketh away and
every branch that beareth fruit he
purgeth it that it may bring forth more
fruit
now you are all clean through the word
which i have spoken unto you do you see
something special in that verse
the word you cannot divorce it no
you cannot
put this away
and then
by the spirit walk now this is
fascinating because the devil
the devil is a master at separating the
word from your actions
abide in me and i in you so how do you
abide in christ
by staying rooted in the word right
okay and then you will bear much fruit
i am the vine you are the branches he
that abideth in me and i in him the same
shall bring forth much fruit for without
me you can do nothing
again
that tells us that
we are not the bee's knees
we can do nothing in our own strength if
it is not
supported by the holy spirit
then it is a useless exercise
in verse 7 it says if you abide in me
and my words abide in you
you shall ask what you will and it shall
be done unto you
again martin
how often must he say it
if you abide in me and
my words abide in you then
this is the only basis for our religion
we have no other creed except for the
bible
the spirit of prophecy is a lesser light
that shows
the greater light and brings to a fall
the power of the message that's it and
so it can never
be
in contrast
to the bible
and that's why whenever you find
conflicts
between the spirit of prophecy and the
bible make sure you've got the right
version of the bible
because
that can
cause controversy you're absolutely
right
now again if we continue here it talks
about the love which he has as the
father has loved me so have i loved you
continued in my love and then it gives
again the condition if you keep my
commandments
you shall abide in my love
now martin let me just get this straight
did god love us while we were yet
sinners yes yes because while we were
yet sinners he died for us
so
the issue of him loving us is not
conditional
but abiding in his love
is conditional
in other words
when when it came to jerusalem he said
jerusalem jerusalem how often i wanted
to take you under my wing but you would
not now your house has been left for you
desolate
he said that with a tear in his eye not
because he wanted to reject them but
because they had rejected him
and he honored their decision that's and
that will be at the end exactly the same
exactly the same
so he's got a condition
yes and then he says these things have i
spoken unto you that my joy might remain
in you
and that your joy might be full but
there's a condition to that that's it it
comes again
verse 13 says greater love is no man
than this that a man lay down his life
for his friends and ye are my friends
if
you do what i command you martin can it
be plainer
how does christianity get away with it
by denying
the very basis of the centrality of the
gospel of john
and why did like he says here
no greater love than this that the man
laid down his life for his friends
did he lay his life down for them
absolutely and you know what he says he
says i do not call you servants but i
call you friends
this is the amazing thing about the
character of god
that
he didn't create you to be a slave
he created you to be a permanent friend
and companion to him
one in mind one in purpose one in
attitude
as the father and jesus are one so we
have to be one but we have to be one in
him too
it it is an amazing god that we are
dealing with here that calls us friends
there's no other deity
in this world
that is like this deity that's why this
one is the only one that is worth
worshipping
he makes it quite plain you have not
chosen me but i have chosen you and
ordained you
in other words the whole world is
arrayed against god
but through this darkness christ reaches
out and he says if i be lifted up i will
draw all men
to you
but if you are in christ
if you are in christ
verse 18 tells us
that the world will hate you
sad
if the world hate you you know that it
hated
me before it hated you if you were of
the world the world would love his own
but because you are not of the world but
i have chosen you out of the world
therefore the world hates you now can we
just stop you if we go back here it's
hate
what if the world hated me but just
before that it says what you must do to
love him yes keep the commandments so if
you go now to what do they do in hating
him
they don't keep his commandments very
good point yes they don't keep his
commandments and if you do keep his
commandments the world will hate you too
if you keep the commandments they will
hate you
remember the word that i said unto you
the servant is not greater than his lord
if they have persecuted me
they will also persecute you
if they have kept my sayings they will
keep yours also
his sayings are his word
right that's what they are so if you
keep the word of god
the world will hate you if you keep the
commandments the world will hate you the
devil was wrath with the woman and went
to make war with the remnant of the seed
they that
keep the commandments and have the faith
of jesus
and that's in revelation
that that's in the book of revelation
it's amazing
god
shows us exactly what we need
to be going through to the end but he
also says look you're gonna have trouble
now i've heard so many times
the opponents say
you people are all works orientated
because it's just about the commandments
the commandments the commandments
well martin how often have we read now
about the commandments
wouldn't they say wouldn't they say
exactly the same to jesus today exactly
they would
they
they can't be any different because the
world hated him then because of it they
crucified him now they and they said we
have no king but caesar and again they
will say give us caesar in fact the
clamoring for caesar right now
please come and mediate between ukraine
and russia
because god is not going to help us they
said that plainly the orthodox priest
said
prayer will not help please pope come
and help us
unbelievable
and the worst of it
is that 21 tells us but all these things
will they do unto you for my name's sake
because they know not him that sent me
they will think that they're doing god's
service in the name of jesus christ if
they persecute those
that keep his commandments and why
because they think
they know me and how did he say you know
you can know him if you keep his going
commandments and if you read the word if
you understand the word and internalize
it you have to eat it
on a daily basis
but it's a it's such a powerful
statement that he says
they will think
that they do it for his name's sake
it shows you how deceived you can be
that
you can do something that you think
you're doing for christ but because
you've got a lack of
reading the word and wanting to do what
god requires from you
it's out of your mind you think you're
doing god a service so
if you take children at school
why do they conform with
the activities of all the others we call
that peer pressure right
now our adults immune from peer pressure
no
not at all do the churches
exert peer pressure
ecumenism
because of peer pressure about what we
think of people are going to think of us
no we have to we have to align ourselves
now martin
do you think it's important that
the world should know about the ten
commandments and obedience to christ and
believe it thus says the lord
your life depends on it
eternal life okay
why was it necessary in revelation
chapter 14
to preach the everlasting gospel again
because they forgot it because they'd
separated the law from the gospel right
it had to be preached again
verse 24
if i had not done amongst them the works
which none other man did
they had not had sin but now have they
both seen and hated both me and my
father
but this cometh to pass that the word
might be fulfilled that is written in
their law they hated me without the
cause
so he's quoting psalms 35 verse 19 they
hated me without the cause they had no
reason to hate him
no
and in which which law was it written
their law their law yes the bible
they had it at their disposal but they
rejected the tenants they are
but then comes about i always like the
word but in the bible when the
comforters come whom i will send unto
you from the father even the spirit of
truth
which proceedeth from the father he
shall testify of me
and you shall bear witness because you
have been with me from the beginning so
there are a number of witnesses the one
witness is the holy spirit that will
testify of jesus
now martin
i don't want to throw too many spanners
in the works here but just the question
if i testify of you
am i someone else than you are yes
let's leave it at that right thank you
and ye also shall bear witness because
you have been with me from the beginning
so the holy spirit will witness in other
words convict the heart and the
disciples will witness
and if you come into harmony with what
we have just read
then you will be a disciple of christ
and if i can bring it also back you
don't have an excuse
because just like them
all was written
in your law and we've got it in our
hands to the law
and to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word it is because
there is no light in them
and then we move to chapter 16
and again he reiterates in verse 2
they shall put you out of the synagogue
yea the time cometh that whoever killeth
you
will think that he doeth god's service
martin do you think that's important
that we should understand this for the
time that we are living in yes because
we're heading for this at a
very quick base are we are we repeating
this history
so what applied here
applies to us
and if you study these these chapters
prayerfully
and you internalize them
wouldn't that strengthen you for the
time and for the conflict that is ahead
exactly because like we've mentioned
earlier jesus is in the boat
so when the storm comes
instead of asking him don't you care you
must
know he's there
because he cares correct
now from verse 7 onward we read more
about the holy spirit nevertheless i
tell you the truth it is expedient for
you that i go away
for if i go not away the comforter will
not come unto you but if i depart i will
send him
unto you
so
martin
who is he sending he's sending someone
to represent him right
and when he has come
he will reprove the world of sin
and of righteousness
and of judgment now those are three
hammer blows
now
if you look at the world today
when they pray for the holy spirit what
are they praying for
power
they're praying for power
but this holy spirit that is referred to
here will reprove the world of sin
big hammer blow i'm a sinner
and what is the contrast of sin
righteousness
righteousness and what is the standard
of judgment the law okay have we had a
lot
of things to say about the law no all
right what is sin by definition
transgression of the law transgression
of the law so martin
is this which the holy spirit will do to
convict the world of sin
righteousness and judgment is that in
harmony with what the holy spirit is
doing in many professed circles today no
no
it's giving you power
and uh it's a power religion it's like a
drug yeah
and it also is many times linked to
prosperity
all right now martin you come out of
that out of those circles right it's not
so long ago that you
you were
enjoying that environment
was it very pleasant for you to find out
that the true function of the holy
spirit was to convict you of sin and
righteousness and judgment in the
beginning it's not
not at all but as you grow
you're very
appreciative
that this is the way
god helps you
if it wasn't for the holy spirit
convicting you of sin you'll just carry
on you'll just carry on and you wouldn't
even be aware of it
now it's got a very interesting twist
here in verse 9 of sin
because they believe not on me
so here's another definition of sin
the sin is not believing in jesus christ
it's
that's interesting right
but of course
you can only be guilty of this sin as he
qualified before he said if it weren't
for my works they would be without sin
right but now that they have seen it and
they reject it therefore their sin
remains
so if you if you are convicted by the
holy spirit and you reject it
then it becomes for your sin
and it also means that you did not
believe christ
of righteousness because i go to my
father and you see me no more
so he goes to his father so now you have
to accept righteousness by faith faith
that's it this is what what verse 10 is
verse 10 is
righteousness by faith that is the third
angel's message in verity
and the third angel's message is linked
to the commandments in particular the
sabbath exactly the fourth one
now have we seen that
throughout this issue when we read
isaiah chapter 58 wasn't that the issue
that had to be restored exactly
so how much depth is there in these
these chapters of judgment
because the prince of this world is
judged
satan
in other words
whatever the theology of satan is
is judged by what we have read here
which is the opposite that's it satan's
philosophy is plainly stated do what
thou wilt is the whole of the law that's
it
and those two concepts are in conflict
salvation by works salvation by faith
so in these verses we have
righteousness by faith
we have the judgment we have all of
these things
now i'm sure that jesus would have liked
to explain it in some more depth because
he says i've yet many things to say unto
you but you cannot bear them now
because they weren't ready to receive it
their mind was still
waiting for
this messiah that would release them
from the roman bondage
verse 13 howbeit when he the spirit of
truth is come he will guide you into all
truth
so
you know just make a list a mental list
of what he does he will convict you of
sin
he will show you what the opposite of
sin is which is righteousness which
means you must move from sin
to righteousness
once you have moved from sin to
righteousness then you do not come into
the judgment
then you are saved by grace through
faith that's it
but then he has another couple of other
functions he will
lead you into the truth because he's
called the spirit of truth and he will
guide you into all truth
now didn't he say my word is truth yes
all right so in other words you cannot
study the bible without the holy spirit
when i was an atheist
i read the bible
i read it like
a mythological story book and i came up
with all kinds of fancy full ideas i
actually wanted to write a book
which i wanted to title the genes of
genesis
which was a book on evolution
and i'm so glad i never wrote it because
it would have been the most foolish
thing that you could ever imagine
because the fool says in his heart there
is no god right
so
he will guide you into all truth i'm so
glad that the holy spirit got hold of me
before i wrote this rubbish
and then read genesis as it stands
and it also brings to mind how important
it is
that you believe
every word
because every word is truth yes how many
can you leave up then nothing so
when you read this
and you read it as it stands
believe it because it's truth and how
many people
bring out all sorts of their own
concoctions all the time
they will guide you into all truth he
will not speak of himself but whatever
you shall hear that he shall speak and
he will show you things to come
so there will be
prophecy
so is jesus here predicting that the
holy spirit will raise up prophets for
the church definitely yes does he
predict the same in revelation
yes
so the gift of prophecy will be retained
until when martin
until the end till the end and he shall
glorify me for ye shall receive of mine
and shall show it unto you
now any religion that glorifies the holy
spirit apart from christ
is not fulfilling verse 14
because the holy spirit has the function
of glorifying christ
so when pope john paul ii said come holy
spirit you are the one that we want to
glorify publicly
is that fulfilling the commission
that we read about here now
no this is a this is a very serious
issue so how important is it that we
study these things this is eternal life
studying
and it's absolutely essential because
every deception that is in the world
today is being addressed
in these chapters every deception
all things that the father has are mine
therefore said i that he shall take of
mine and shall show it unto you
a little while and you shall not see me
and again a little while and you shall
see me because i go to the father so
this is just the prediction
that he will
be going to the father and they will be
dependent upon the word and the guidance
of the holy spirit
and for the rest of chapter 16 he is
reiterating
like a good teacher what he has said
before that we have to stay rooted in
christ
that he is going to the father that we
are to rely upon the word and the
leading of the spirit and then he says
in verse 32
behold the hour cometh yea is now come
that you shall be scattered every man to
his own
and shall leave me alone and yet i am
not alone because the father is with me
these things have i spoken unto you that
in me you might have peace in the world
you shall have tribulation
but be of good cheer i have overcome
the world so it predicts that they will
be scattered
often can we expect a
terrible persecution and a scattering
but be of good
cheer
he has overcome the world
so these are things that we can expect
that brings us
to
the final chapter before
the crucifixion of christ and that is
chapter 17.
so martin chapter 17
is basically a prayer
jesus is praying
that that which he has explained to them
in chapters 14 15 and 16
will be
rooted in their minds and in their
hearts right
so it is it is a glorious
prayer
of dedication
so
when we think of the times we are living
in do you think the time has come where
christ is giving a glorious prayer of
dedication for those that have a message
to present to the world
well he is our intercessor isn't he yes
and soon probation will close
and he says here in verse 2 as thou has
given him power over all flesh that he
should give eternal life to as many as
thou hast given him
and this is life eternal that they made
might know the only true god and jesus
christ whom thou has sent
and then he he talks about
how he has glorified god on earth
through his perfect life
his perfect as be obedience his perfect
humility
and now oh father glorify me with thine
own self with the glory which i had with
thee before the world was
so that shows again the eternity of
christ
in verse 9 he says i pray for them
i pray not
for the world
but for them which thou hast given me
for they
are
thine
this world martin
is coming to an end
we can pray for the world
we can pray for the conversion of the
world
but this world is coming to an end there
is no solution for this world
just like the jews rejected christ
so the world is going to reject christ
so we can only pray that people will
come out of the world
now jesus says in verse 11
and now i am no more in the world but
these are in the world
and i come to the holy father keep
through thine own name those whom thou
has given me
that they may be one
as we are
this is such a powerful prayer
this unity
in the context of the chapters that we
are reading
occurred after the judas principle had
left
and we must expect this prayer
to be of special significance
for the times when the latter rain will
be poured out
because he says quite plainly while i
was with them in the world i kept them
in thy name
those that thou gavest me i've kept and
none of them is lost
but the son of perdition that the
scripture might be fulfilled
so
if we abide in christ if we are rooted
in his word if we keep his commandments
none of us will be lost if we
appropriate righteousness by faith
through faith
then
none will be lost but the son of
perdition the judas principle will have
to leave he says in verse 17 sanctify
them through thy truth thy word is truth
so it puts another stamp on it
that we must be rooted in the word of
god
and i just want to read verse 18 as well
as thou has sent me into the world even
so i also sent them into the world they
were back
at
what our duty is yes this is our duty
just as
the man was sent to the pool of siloam
which means he was sent
so he that was born
blind and now could see
was sent
when he was sent they kicked him out
it
right
we can expect exactly the same we were
blind
god gave us spiritual eyesight we are
sent we're not going to be received very
well
but
but we're still sent we're still sent
but thank god not all
will reject the message just as they
didn't all reject the message
then
it says in verse 20 which is the
the final paragraph
of this chapter
it says neither prayer for these alone
but for them also which will which shall
believe on me through their word
so that holy spirit
will go with god's people throughout all
the ages and here in the end
for their ears only
he tells them this wonderful story that
people will believe through their word
but their word
will be
one with god's word with jesus's word
because that it has to be in harmony
that's what the whole time they said
that they all may be one as thou father
art in me and i and thee and that they
also may be one in us that the world may
believe that thou sent me so imagine if
there are all kinds of movements like
economical movements etc
and
world inter-religious
unifications and fraternities
that reject the very tenants of what we
have read here
then that is not an argument that we
should be one with error
it's amazing because they want to be one
to to establish peace
yes but how can they be peace if you
the oneness that you are
trying to
get
is not based on the word of god
absolutely and the glory which thou
gavest me
i have given them that they may be one
even as we are one now when it comes to
the glory
the glory is always the character of
christ
and
we have to emulate that character
it's very hard we have a fallen nature
so
we have to cling to christ
and realize that without
his indwelling spirit
we have no hope of salvation
man and let go of the things that you
want to keep on to that's in conflict
with us yes
and we must also remember that
presumption
is god's counterfeit to faith
i in them and thou in me that they may
be made perfect in one
and that the world may know that thou
sent me and has loved them as thou has
loved me
this is a beautiful prayer the only way
that we can be perfect is if he is in us
christ in us
the hope
of glory says the bible
father i will that they also whom there
has given me be with me where i am that
they may behold my glory which thou has
given me for thou loveth
me before the foundations of the world
this is the very essence of the plan of
salvation
christ
uniting humanity
back with divinity planting his cross
between a separated god and humanity and
uniting with his divine arm grabbing the
throne of god with his human arm
embracing humanity
opening the way being the ladder
that unites us
with divinity
and he wants us to be with him in heaven
to see him in all his glory not even
moses
could see that without being hidden in
the cleft of the rock and then only from
the back imagine seeing this glory
face to face
if you are a sinner martin
and you cling to sin
then you will be consumed by this glory
because the bible says
that people will be destroyed by the
brightness of his coming
a righteous father the world has not
known thee but i have known thee and
these have known
that thou sent me and i have declared
unto them thy name
and will declare it that the love
wherewith that has loved me may be in
them
and i
in them
martin that is the culmination
of the final
final
instruction
to the disciples
it is the message for our time
and then follows the story of
the
crucifixion so may god
bless these words to us
may we study them
prayerfully
and be safeguarded from many a pitfall
in the world
if we internalize these words yeah and
may we
do what these words say
and go to the world with it
let's
be sent
heavenly father you have given us an
instruction
we need to be rooted in you we need to
be rooted in the word we need to
understand
the plan of salvation we need to
understand the relationship between law
and grace we need to understand the
workings of the holy spirit
and we need to go to the world and warn
them
bring them back to
obedience repair the breach and the wall
and point them back to the author of
creation
and the author
of recreation that mud lord
that mud in the beginning and that mud
that was placed on the eyes
pointing to the creator god and his
authority and his willingness and
his longing for a relationship
which is embodied in the fourth
commandment
help us to bring this message to the
world in jesus name amen amen
so
[Music]
you